bonjour
[Music]
the european commission on behalf of the
eu has today dispersed 600 million
in macro financial assistance to ukraine
this is the second and final trench
under ukraine's current mfa program
following the first 600 million
disbursement in december 2020
this disbursement is part of the 3
billion emergency mfa package
for 10 enlargement and neighborhood
partners
this package aims to help them limit the
economic fallout of the covet 19
pandemic
the program is a concrete demonstration
of the eu solidarity with its partners
to help respond to the economic impact
of the covet 19 pandemic
more information is available in today's
daily news and the press release that we
have just published
thank you very much very this concludes
our
announcements for today so
let me ask if you have questions yes
please
thank you eric um question for dan
uh just wondering if you can give us a
bit of insight into
how the commission filled last week's
talks with britain went over the
northern ireland protocol did you see
any encouragement
in what you heard from the british side
and then could you give us a look
forward to what's happening this week
please thank you
done
hi joe thanks very much for your
question um i think let's just start at
the the starting point you know that we
came forward with far-reaching measures
and proposals two weeks ago since then
we have been engaging constructively and
intensively with our uk counterparts
those discussions will continue in
london this week and vice president
schaefkvich of course will meet um david
frost they also spoke together on the
phone last week i'm not now going to
provide a running commentary on these
talks i think we now need to to have the
space to to find solutions you know that
our proposals that we put on the table
two weeks ago we're not presented as a
take it or leave it type approach we
want to discuss this with the uk and
that's where we are
thank you any other questions on the
discussions with the uk please only keep
your hand raised
in the chat if your questions relate to
this jennifer
something else
sorry jennifer we just didn't have your
question
okay
so i see no further questions on uh this
so i go back to
um thomas who i believe
had raised his hand thomas
the question is for tim
um
i wanted to ask if he could confirm
reports that the
eu delegation to glasgow into cop 26 in
glasgow will not be attending social
events because of concerns over covet 19
in the uk
is that are these reports correct and
could you also give us an idea of the
size of the eu delegation and what kind
of events they would not be attending or
would be attending in glasgow thank you
hi jennifer um so first of all i think
it's important to say that the eu is
fully committed to doing everything that
it can to make a success of cop 26 is a
very important priority
for us um regarding these stories which
appeared over the weekend i can confirm
that we have not issued any guidelines
and to our delegation regarding
socializing or attending external events
during the cop and the officials
attending the conference will
adhere to the the sanitary restrictions
and safety measures which are put in
place by the cop presidency and by the
unf triple c and of course we have full
confidence
in those
the eu will not be organizing its its
usual annual reception and due to the
conflict restrictions
but our senior representatives have
scheduled multiple bilateral meetings
we'll be taking apart will be taking
part in in various events as usual so
there's really no question of of our
diplomatic efforts being curbed in any
way by the current situation and we are
fully committed to engaging with with
all other stakeholders uh as well as we
usually do during the cop as you know
there's a big program of side events
events with other delegations as well
when we receive those invitations
they're treated as always um based on
the
level of priority the availability of
the of the officials that we have there
and that's the the only criteria for
deciding whether we we take part in any
events or not
your final question was about the size
of the delegation i i don't have those
numbers at the moment but i i've asked
and i will get those as soon as i can
for you
thank you very much um so are there
other questions on cup 26 and or climate
policy
daffy
can you hear me is this working it is go
ahead it is okay um yeah sorry question
for tim again um
uh i see from the european renewables
energy foundation that they're quite
angry that the commission appears uh
will sign a memorandum of understanding
with bill gates's uh breakthrough energy
catalysts
and that part of this
has to do with um you know nuclear small
small modular nuclear reactors
i was wondering if you could confirm
that the memorandum will be signed with
gates's uh initiative
and then what is the stand stance on
small nuclear reactors
you know
is there not some form of nuclear um
technology neutrality here that's been
broken
well i mean first of all on on the
declaration i mean i'm not in a position
to confirm anything that that might be
happening
at cop cop26 obviously there'll be a
number of things that we're doing in
terms of events announcements
commitments but these will be
um be announced at the appropriate time
when they're sufficiently mature
um in terms of
partnership with with bill gates in this
breakthrough venture perhaps johannes
will want to come up after me because
it's something um which we've we've
worked on in the past and he can perhaps
um
give the state of play um but that's all
i really have to say for now i think
on the issue of nuclear we've we've uh
we've said multiple times where we stand
not on this issue and i don't have any
particular any specific additions to
make
thank you very much
audi turn questions for like advances
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
negotiation
you
[Music]
me
mercedes uh
i would like to ask on the commission's
reaction on the decision by the turkish
president erdogan to declare 10 western
ambassadors persona non grata thank you
thank you peter
hi thank you very much for the question
well of course we took note and we are
following very closely the developments
regarding the recent announcement by
president erdogan uh in relation to the
statement made by ambassadors of 10
countries in the follow-up to their call
on turkey to implement the ruling of the
european court of human rights in the
case of osman cavalla
the whole situation is a serious matter
but we understand that the consent
countries have not yet been notified
about any action so at this stage i
would refrain from further commenting on
the issue
okay thank you very much are there other
foreign related questions for peter yes
please
go ahead
they perform a duel
uh thank you eric i have actually two
questions one on sudan and the other one
on afghanistan
on sudan what are your reactions
to
reports that there is a coup underway
and many political leaders have been
arrested
and on afghanistan can you confirm media
reports that the eu is to open its
mission or reopen
it's a mission in kabul thank you
thank you very much nawab for your
question i will first
answer on sudan
you have seen probably the tweet by the
hrvp early this morning
the eu is very concerned
about sudan's military forces reportedly
putting
prime minister hamduk under house arrest
and as well as detaining other members
of the civilian leadership
and we urge for their fast release
we have seen also the reports of cuts of
telephone and internet in sudan we
urgently call for unrestrictive means of
communication to reach those in need
violence and bloodshed must be avoided
at all costs
as the broader region faces multiple
challenges protecting sudan's historic
transition has become more acute than
ever
all stakeholders are expected to
implement the different aspects of the
constitutional declaration and the juba
peace agreement in good faith and with
continued spirit of collaboration for
the benefit of the sudanese people who
can who deserve and wish for peace
legitimate uh peace stability and
economic development
as you know a democratic sudan with
fully legitimate civilian government
that ensures peace freedom and justice
for the sudanese people remains the best
guarantee for the long-term stability of
the country and the broader region and
as i said hrvp this morning called on
all stakeholders and the regional
partners to push
back to put back on track the transition
process we remain in close contract in
close contact with the african union and
our partners on the ground and the eu
remains committed to that goal and calls
all stakeholders in sudan and the
country
of the region to follow the same path
so we'll stay with questions on sudan
for the moment before coming to your
other question
nawab
i
believe that
sallam had a question
salam to interact you
thank you eric actually the crisis it
might be worse in the during the coming
hours in sudan and now protesting in all
over the streets in khartoum and other
cities and i don't know if you will
accept in the coming hours after al
burhan speech now
if he if he will offer another
to form another government it will be
accepted to you from your side or
are you gonna think about uh sanctions
by example if the
political process will not go back to
them to normal like before what happened
what happened today morning
well thanks for your question salam but
as you know your question started with
an if
the situation is extremely fluid in
sudan right now it is happening as we
speak things are changing every at every
moment for the moment we have our first
reaction and we will see when the
situation becomes clearer uh what will
happen
are there further questions on
sudan
that is not the case we'll go briefly to
the question on afghanistan
yes
on afghanistan as you know we and i've
said it a few times before we are
working on establishing a minimal
presence on the ground
for security reasons we cannot enter
into the details
as we have repeatedly said also this is
not a sign of recognition we want to be
able to better assist the afghan people
who need our help by being closer and
inevitably we need to engage with the
taliban
be it to facilitate the safe passage of
eu citizens and
afghans at risk and to ensure the
continued access of humanitarian aid
thank you very much
um
i see no further question on this so we
go to
uh chen with a question on taiwan
just for you as well
go ahead
vice president
vestaj last week talked about taiwan in
lance's speech i think i triggered a lot
of news reports so
may i ask you to clarify a few things
whether that signals the european
union's changing of his policy regarding
taiwan
more specifically on the one china
policy second
is the commission supporting or
endorsing like lithuania's move to
change the names of taiwan office and
thirdly
because
her talker mentioned a lot about the
status quo
actually it was the chinese side always
say it's the u.s i mean since the trump
administration has constantly changed
the status quo
on the taiwan strait such as by sending
senior official you know zero you know
multiple actions thank you very much
thanks jen for your question i mean i
think the uh the
the speech by commissioner verstagger on
behalf of the hrvp was very clear and it
speaks for itself the eu develops uh
relations and cooperation with
taiwan within the framework of the one
china policy the eu recognizes the
government of the people's republic of
china as the seoul government of china
at the same time the eu and its member
states have an interest in further
developing ties with taiwan
and an important economic high-tech and
like-minded partner in asia and the eu
welcomes initiatives aiming to boost
taiwanese investment and enhance trade
relations with uh with the eu and we
want to build upon the strong economic
links that already exist between the eu
and taiwan
thank you um
are there other questions on taiwan or
relations with china
i don't believe um this is sorry
there is no oh sorry
i couldn't see you apologies for that
that's okay it's finbarr here from the
south china morning post nabila i wanted
to ask about the situation in hong kong
um this morning we've seen the second
person convicted under the national
security law um we've also seen the ngo
amnesty international say it's going to
close down its hong kong offices before
the end of the year yesterday in the
hong kong marathon we had runners
being asked to cover up their political
slogans before they were allowed to be
admitted to the race i'm wondering uh do
you have any comments on these events
but also um can you maybe confirm
whether there are any plans to revisit
the conclusions on hong kong which were
abandoned and or maybe dropped from the
agenda in april and may from the foreign
affairs council thank you
thanks a lot for your question uh
finbarr and to tell you the truth i have
to
go back on my hong kong
lines here
um
yes i mean we have seen the report in
the uh that the amnesty has decided to
close its hong kong office
the eu reiterates of course it's
concerned about the rapidly uh shrinking
space for civil society in hong kong
as stated in the past the eu calls on
china to act in accordance with its
international commitments and to respect
hong kong's rights and freedoms
and this is what i can say at this point
and in time
thank you
um
catherine i believe you have a question
for nabila
yes hello nabila
hi um my question is about the
the the high representative's visit to
rwanda
and uh i can see from the
the website that he will be meeting with
uh president kagame
and i was wondering if you could say
whether the high representative will
raise the issue of uh spyware in
particular
um
that investigation finds that uh
the the rwanda government have been
using it to spy not just on their own
citizens but
way beyond their own territory to other
african governments and to
and on the the daughter of paul recess
and uh has also been targeted and will
you also be raising the issue of his
unfair trial which the belgian foreign
minister described uh
as
as unfair and
uh will you be saying something about
that thanks
um thanks a lot as you as you know the
hrvp will be meeting
with
the president
this is something that we would be
probably communicating after his uh his
uh meeting
um
as you know when it comes to
i cannot anticipate what will be said
during the meeting our um our
we were very clear about our line
our position on the situation of paul
jose bagina
we have um
commander
we have raised his issue at all level uh
and at this point in time i cannot say
and i cannot anticipate what the hrvp
will be discussing with the president
later on this afternoon
thank you
uh is it on on this
on rwanda
uh on afghanistan okay please uh
hold on so
let's try to stick to different things
are there other questions on rwanda
well catherine if you want to follow up
please raise your hand
okay it does not seem to be working for
um
some
reason
so uh catherine please follow up
bilaterally then with nabila afterwards
you had a question on afghanistan so
let's come back to afghanistan
uh
afghanistan data is
92
below the poverty line very likely in
winter
afghanistan going to face
famine
is there any coordination or preparation
if
it occurs in afghanistan it is the data
is basically
demonstrating that it will happen that
afghanistan will face famine thank you
i mean thanks khalid for your question
this is obviously
a situation that is extremely concerning
to us the hrvp has been
very vocal when it comes to the
situation in afghanistan and
the the when it comes to either the
economic situation or the humanitarian
one
maybe my colleagues can come back to you
on what we are doing in terms of
humanitarian but it is exactly what we
are trying to to to help the afghan
people and we stand by the afghan people
as much as we can and this is exactly
the reason why we are
engaging with the taliban to be able to
have a safe access of humanitarian goods
to afghanistan to help the afghan people
and let me simply add to this um
the uh statement that the president
of the european commission made after
the last european council
as you know afghanistan is one of the
issues which was discussed during the
european council and
let me quote
the president
on this
she said that of the european council
had been discussing the critical
situation
in afghanistan and that right now
even before the winter afghan people
need desperately food water shelter and
access to health care every second
person in afghanistan is in the need of
humanitarian support and the europe is
taking a leadership position here in the
global solidarity effort and she said
last week i presented an afghan support
package worth one billion euros and it
prioritizes the humanitarian needs so
clearly this is something on which the
commission is very committed and will
continue working on
other questions on
foreign
affairs i have a few follow-ups related
to um
related to issues that we had previously
discussed so let me come back to maria
who had raised her hand previously again
on turkey
maria
hello thanks for the floor actually it's
a follow up on irini's question
and
what did you consider to react
as euro as the european commission when
the turkish notification arrives to the
member states
and could this reaction be
the declaration of the turkish
representative in the eu as persona non
grata
thanks
thank you maria let's cross that bridge
when we get there so let's not jump
ahead of the events and as i said we
will refrain from further comments at
this stage since we understand that the
country is concerned have not been
notified about any specific decision yet
thank you janis is your question on this
as well
okay
thank you very much for your
understanding
okay very good
are there
other questions on this um
on this topic
please only keep your hand raised in the
chat if it is on this
franz you have a question on turkey
no
it's something else
uh
okay
now me is your question on turkey
it's on foreign affairs slash
humanitarian aid
okay i see no other question on turkey
so go ahead
thank you uh naomi andery irish times um
my question is about the designation of
six palestinian ngos as terrorist
organizations by israel um so i
understand that at least some of them
would have been recipients of eu funding
or have been
partners um humanitarian aid partners of
the eu at some point so i was wondering
if you have a response to this
and any more detail that you could offer
us thank you
thank you naomi of course we noted the
listing of six palestinian organizations
by israel's ministry of defense last
week
some of these are receiving eu funding
to be more precise two of them
and we take it very seriously all the
allegations that are raised we are
looking into those allegations and we
are in touch with israeli partners to
seek clarifications
on on these things let me recall that uh
our funding the european union's funding
to palestinian and civil society
organizations is an important element of
our support for the two-state solution
and our support to palestinians
thank you
other questions on this mosey i believe
you have a question on this
thank you very much
peter comment on this fairly decision
during the weekend to outlaw
six ngos for alleged context
this popular front for palestine
and uh
i wonder has the commission or member
states uh have they received an evidence
that their funding had been transferred
to a terrorist organization that's one
question the other question is i
understand there is some kind of legal
document written last year by
an organization called the
european legal support office
which analyzes let's say
legislation in this area and obviously
the council can put place restrictive
measures against funding ngos
but that only unless it goes for the
organization themselves not for
national persons so it doesn't let's say
stop
such persons from
let's say using the funding or transfer
them to an
organization a to auto terrorist
organization is that the kind of
loophole
in current
eu legislation thank you
peter
thank you moza um i'll try to take your
points one by one um
as i said we take the allegations very
seriously we are looking into it and we
are seeking clarifications from the
israeli partners on the on the recent
listings past allegations and past
suspicions of misuse of eu funds in
relation to certain palestinian
organizations
where have not been substantiated in the
past but again we continue our
engagement with the israeli authorities
on this issue
on
the second point you raised about this
organization well i'm not really up to
us to comment uh products by others and
if there is a loophole well let me
underline one thing which is very
important to bear in mind when it comes
to uh european union funding uh in
general and specifically also to when it
comes to palestinian organizations and
palestinian territories that we continue
to stand by international law and
support the civil society organizations
which have a role to play in promoting
international law human rights and
democratic values and vc civil society
is an important contributor to good
governance and sustainable development
in the eu in israel in palestine and
elsewhere in the world and the eu has a
lot of safeguards in place in order to
make sure that the funding is being used
in line with the eu legislation and
measures instruments and actions to take
if it's proven otherwise
thank you very much
other other foreign relations related
questions for us today
catherine i see that uh you have managed
to raise your hand i believe you want to
come back to wanda let's have a short
follow-up
on wanda and then we will move on to
non-foreign affairs related topics
catherine
hi
so yes it is a follow-up um on my
question to nabila but
it's a more general question something
that i don't really understand so maybe
peter could could answer it i mean i i
trying to understand when the the the
european external action service sends a
statement out when it doesn't
so for example in the state of two
canadian nationals
michael kovrick and michael spavor who
didn't have a
fair trial didn't have access to a
lawyer
the the service sent out uh a statement
however when it is uh
paul recess abagina who is uh who has uh
belgian citizenship
uh
there there was no statement so can you
please explain to me
when
why why didn't you send out a statement
about the situation in relation to uh
recession
and why did you in the instance of the
canadian nationals i mean can you please
explain to me what the difference is
first of all um thanks catherine and i
don't think we can really compare both
it's two different contexts it's two
different countries what i want to go
back to is what the hrvp said at his ep
urgency debate on the 7th of october and
here he said we are
aware of the concern about the due
process his access to lawyers legal
documents and time for preparation
however we note that the authorities
remedied many of the issues after that
they
after they had been raised with them
beyond the procedural concerns which
clearly merit to be expressed we should
not lose sight of the serious
allegations against the accused and the
body of evidence presented by
prosecution
much of which provided through
cooperation with member states
prosecution authorities as i said we
have monitored the trial both in the
courtroom and online and that we are
very much in contact with the competent
belgian authorities
uh and we have had also regular which
have had also regular contact uh access
to raza zakum
to mr
rusev bagina and kept us informed
thank you very much okay
thank you nabila we will now move to
non-foreign relation related issues uh
yes please
uh hi jess parker bbc news it's on
fishing um
clemont bone appeared to set a sort of
deadline for the end of this month to
resolve the dispute between
the uk and france the eu on fishing
licenses i just wondered
do you recognize that deadline of the
31st of october for some kind of
resolution and where are we in those
discussions
thanks we had a very first question on
the uk
at the beginning so we're forcing us to
come back to this issue but tim will
answer your question uh yeah but i
really won't have anything new to say
for you jess i think you've asked
vivian several times where we stand on
this issue and the commission is fully
committed to ensuring full
implementation
and application of the trading
cooperation agreement with the uk
as a matter of top priority we're in
constant contact with eu authorities to
ensure that all license applications are
dealt with as soon as possible
as soon as possible is that it's the
time frame that we're talking about this
will provide continuity for the fish and
activities of the concerned eu fishermen
and women i think you know as you know
this is a complex exercise in particular
for the small
smaller vessels but yeah i really have
nothing more to add that you haven't
heard before
thank you very much
are there other questions on um fishing
licenses
that is not the case thank you tim we go
to momsheel who's been asking for the
floor for a while mom should go ahead
good afternoon
my question is
about the bulgarian national plan for
recovery and resilience which was uh
once trans uh was handed by bulgaria to
european commission uh yes the european
commission already began the process of
the assessment
and if so at which stage is this process
and can we expect the final approval of
this plan until the end of the year
thank you
thank you and mom she we're not going to
provide a running commentary on the
assessment of the bulgarian national
plan i can confirm that the assessment
has of course
already
started and is ongoing and we will
report when
the assessment is
finalized
whether it is before after the end of
the year i cannot say for
for the moment obviously
[Music]
okay any other questions on
the national recovery plans
for us today
no on other issues
thomas
welcome back
yes uh thank you eric i know you
normally don't comment on comments but
this is the
justice minister of hungary who made the
tweet on saturday
basically saying we we said no to the
soviet empire in 1956 and we say no to
the imperial ambitions of brussels
so i wonder when are you planning to
invade hungary i'm busy on thursday by
the way
thank you we never comment on uh
comments as you know
and let me remind you that uh hungary
joined the european uh union of its own
free will
after a
referendum and therefore its place is
obviously within the european union
thank you
i see one hand raised so let's move on
to
[Music]
is
um
um
continue
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh hi erica adam parsons from sky news
just a quick one have you has the
commission received
any communications from david sasoli yet
about his threat to instigate legal
proceedings if the conditionality
mechanism isn't triggered by november
the second
i'm
not in a position to answer that
question we will check and we will
follow up and
and
reply to you
any other question for us today
no so thank you very much and see you
tomorrow